America, let's cross it. Here we are. Once upon a time, the Americas. This is the story I'm going
to tell you. From Siberia to the Pacific, the tribes set out to walk. They braved oceans.
They crossed continents in pursuit of their dreams of freedom. The adventure was sometimes dramatic.
Often, it was the end of heroes. It's not easy, but it's magical to create a brand new,
beautiful country. We took up the torch, going further, going higher, and their dream came true.
Now they are here, the Americas as you imagined them.
It's up to you to make them the fantastic world that we all dreamed of at one time or another.
Everything worked out for us to reach our destiny on this earth without hoping for a land of brotherhood.
So we saw our friends go all the way south while other tribes spread out towards the Great Lakes or California.
I also told you what life was like in the far north.
Let's now look at the groups that will settle on this immense plateau between the Rocky Mountains and the Sierra Nevada.
The large basin given by there.
The living conditions there are not the easiest either.
Game is rare and during the winter, they feed on everything that can be gathered.
Nuts, pine nuts, roots.
And in the summer, they migrate.
Oh, it's really nice here.
We should stay here.
Yeah, did you see?
There are lots of fish.
Oh, it's nice here.
You know, there are lots of fish.
Oh, and if we stay, dad, please say yes.
What do you think?
That's a good idea.
Hum.
Let's see.
The wind is good.
The landscape pretty and then oh there are ducks and cooked to perfection.
That's all I'm telling you, my children.
Well, okay.
We're staying.
Exclamation mark.
Well done.
Excellent place, isn't it?
Really excellent.
Ah.
Oh.
So guys, you're doing well, I see.
And you know, mom, I caught the biggest one.
Is that true?
You should go up there and see what's happening to our big friend.
Maestro told me that with this.
I'm going to catch loads of fish.
You'll see what you'll see.
Not the head.
And don't even think we're going to bite the empty hook.
Well, I've seen some.
I'm leaving.
You don't look happy.
What's going on?
Look, there are loads of fish.
Well, I can't even catch a single one.
Here, eat.
I found some good stuff today.
Why do you want to catch these fish, huh?
We could eat in style.
Well, give them something to eat too.
But I'm not here to feed the fish.
But so that they can feed me?
Well, give them something to eat first.
Oh, I have a good idea.
I'll try it.
Give it to you now and have fun fishing.
You were right, maestro. Look, I have plenty of fish here. So, you don't like fish? Oh no,
you don't even think I'm going to let you eat my fish? This place is great, really great. I found
a good spot. There will be pine nuts and walnuts to last all winter. That's good news. Yes, the
cold is coming and we shouldn't delay. Ah, it's not far off. Hey, there's a lot of late this year
and we could do a hunt. We don't have enough people for that. Check out the neighbors. Maybe
we could ask them to join in. Good idea. And you know how to cook rabbit perfectly. Chop this. Here,
we'll have to dig to be better sheltered in my opinion. Catch me. Who's that, huh? Who's that?
People who are chiefs of foreigners. What are they doing here, huh? Can you tell me? The same
thing we did, chief. Taking up their winter quarters, huh? What? We're going to chase them
out of here. Say, what if we hunted rabbits with them? They might have nets. Oh yes, they marched.
that changes everything good idea very very good idea and we'll chase them out later he took me by
the hand and then oh oh that's it of course it's obvious how could we have done without them well
yes we could have done without them what but what are you saying master no nothing at all nothing at
all i'm not saying anything are you the boss well i'm the boss i mean we're over there and we
occupied the land before you. So, uh. The rabbits, the rabbits, chief. Oh, oh, yes, where do? You have
rabbits? I mean, rabbit nets. Uh, yes, a few. Why? Uh, because there are plenty of rabbits. So we could
go hunting together and catch lots of rabbits. Lots. But then, well, then, it's every man for
himself. Okay, okay, we'll do it like this. And like this, we can find them everywhere. Of course,
they're like weeds. But still, we didn't have to stumble upon them. Excuse me?
And what do you say?
What do I say? What do I say? But I'm not saying anything. I'm not saying anything at all.
Hey, there you go. And I'll take this one. And tell me what you think. I agree. There you go.
I agree. This place is excellent. Yes, but we're going to have to build houses to shelter us in
the winter. It's close now. We'll start here. So what are they doing? Tell me what are they doing?
They dug up, chief, and now they're covering it with branches like this and like that.
Well, we're doing the same thing.
Come on, come on.
It'll be nice here, chief.
We'll be sheltered.
Not really, chief.
We'll see.
What do you think?
We know how to do it.
Not really, chief.
What I'm saying, shut up and dig.
Traditions say that far away, at the bottom of the plateau where we are, and after walking
for moons, we come across an immense expanse of water and we find very strange creatures.
They have horns in their mouths and crawl around on their behinds.
There are also fish as big as mountains.
Tell me, why don't we ever go and see all these things, master?
Ah, when winter is over, why not?
Why not?
Ah, that.
Question mark.
Good ideas if we're good chiefs, right?
We'll be sheltered?
We know how to do it, don't we, chief?
We'll be good chief.
I didn't know, chief.
I couldn't know, chief.
I didn't know.
We're the best, right?
Right?
we're the best. I have the feeling that this country is worthless to us. We're going to have
to go down to the valley. That's how, through their adventures or my adventures, men will
continue their migration and this for centuries. You have to work and participate in the common
effort. We're tired. We need to rest. Yeah, we're tired. Very tired. That's true. I even think
we're sick. I have a kind of pain here. Every time I lift up my chest, I got hit too hard on
my foot. So, I said very well. So, go see the elder, she'll heal you. Wait for me, wait for me.
Come on, my totem, my totem, I'm suffering. Oh my, what am I suffering? Oh, my foot hurts. Oh,
my foot hurts. Go see the elder and he will heal you. Wait for me, please. Wait for me.
Go see the elder who will heal you. Go see the elder, he will heal you. Otherwise,
we wouldn't go see the elder. This country doesn't give us anything. Let's see what's
happening elsewhere. Wait for me. Wait for me, you over there. See that one? I bet he's going to see
the elder to get healed. Like this, there's a beaver. Like this, an eagle and like this, like this.
And like this, it'll be a bear. Like this, like this, a fish. Oh yes, like this, a crow. And like
this. What is it, huh? What is it? Great shaman, I've come to consult you. Well, tell me. And there
you have it. Since yesterday, when I look to the right, I see on the left. And when I... When you
look to the left you see to the right oh well how do you know that i know my job is to know and i
also know that you've fallen on your head that's right i fell on my head what do you need to heal
yourself here oh well here and there you go now you're going to turn around ah fantastic i look
to the right and i see to the right yes yes and if you look to the left you see to the left science
is something, there's no doubt about it. Oh, that's true. Yes, there's only one thing to.
Do. Look, this one's not bad, huh? Say, what a beautiful arrow. Let's.
Stop. There's more than enough for all of us. Yes, I think you're right. It would be funny to
hunt a big beast like that. What for? We don't need it. So, let's let it live.
Huh. There you go. Very good. Stay there until you get to the pot.
Dad, look what we found. Look, it's good to eat. For all that, the northwest coast was a
veritable paradise on earth and their standard of living was much higher than that of other
Indian peoples. Food was plentiful and there was time to make ornamental objects. What are you
doing, maestro? I have an idea. It could bring rain. So, I'll try. This modern science is strange,
strange. Oh yes. Master, now that I'm no longer renting, she wants to marry me but she also loves
another man. So, can she finally marry us both? Why not? You too. If you have the means, you can
marry two women, of course, but no more than two. You'll have to feed them, clothe them. And based
on my old experience, young man, one is quite enough. But what is he talking about? These people
weren't bigamists after all. But yes, well no, well in the Aida's tribes, well, it was accepted
to have two wives or two husbands if one had the means and he had them. And so in the end for them
everything is fine it's not too soon after the hard life and all the misery they have known but
abundance of very little sight it takes a lot of common sense to resist it otherwise what you are
about to see happens look closely chief chief i have come to tell you about chief nabo's invitation
yes he is preparing a big party and he says he will give you magnificent gifts this little naboo
huh who do i take this loser for we are going to show him that we are much richer than he is
Come on, you guys, get ready. Our neighbor, the stubborn chief that you invited to the soup,
well, he is coming with his entourage, Big Chief.
Hello, Little Chief Naboo.
Hello, Big Chief 2. In honor of my son, you are a man now. I have invited you and yours to come
and participate in this celebration. And also so that you can admire my riches which are great.
I will first offer you a meal like you have never known. Then I will give you gifts.
Gifts like you have never seen before. A dough with red bear fat, beaver. A goat roasted from
beard to tail. We call that a barbecue. Do you know what it is? Halibut, smelts, crane, cod
cooked in sperm whale fat. That is the new cuisine. Sperm whale beans, carraways, leeks and persimmons.
We have this ex. What do you think, big chef? It is magnificent. No, go ahead, gorge yourself.
I have the means. I can offer you all that. It is very good. Very good. It is good. Now,
i'm going to give you some magnificent presents a hairbrush cut from the tail of any spike and
decorated with cottage a dancing shirt made of scottish fiber and goat wool beautiful woven
baskets and engraved metal copper a stick with an eagle's claw to scratch your back that looks
like chicken flu yes there's this superb totem and for each of you i offer sumptuous handmade
blankets are there still many blankets left when we burn them your gifts are very modest i thank
you anyway but you'll see the ones i brought you are more sumptuous show me these famous presents
a square blanket more beautiful than yours a medicine ball with flowers and herbs that heal
a totem bigger than yours a decorated wooden safe an ornate bison horn that will allow you to hear
because you're going deaf huh so little chief aren't my gifts good i'm not deaf admit that my
gifts are more beautiful my gifts are the most beautiful because i am the greatest of chiefs
i am the greatest and also the most powerful the chief do you think that's a big fat miserable soup
a big fat sack of meat oh maestro was that really how it happened as wealth accumulated these men
became more and more boastful and faced with all these excesses in the 20th century patelch was
declared an outlaw ameria atlantis this is the americas from north to the pacific once upon a
the time, I was the America. That's the story I told you. The elders themselves.